in these Chronicles fire and blood there
are a lot of dragons I love dragons
what the dragon represents to you well
that's an interesting question now you
know of course I love dragons initially
in the work of other people reading
stories about dragons when I was young
there's just something cool about
dragons and it's interesting how many
societies have dragons in their
mythology and why is that you know that
dragons are different our Western
dragons are very different from say the
Dragons of Asia of China and and the
kingdoms of the Far East but what they
do have dragons and what is the dragon
you know that he was on a heraldic
symbols of the Welsh King Arthur was
Arthur Pendragon he was all tied up with
the mythologies of dragons my namesake
st. George got his sainthood by killing
a dragon yes if you look at those
engravings it seemed to be a very small
drag and it was about the same size as
George himself and many of the statues
and carvings that I've seen token gave a
Smaug and the other great dragons was
similarly on all very powerful mythical
animals so and in your books they
establish a very special connection with
the person who rides who rides them it's
almost it's almost the continuation
right you well that you have to bond
yeah you have to bond with the dragon
there's no way you can physically
intimidate a dragon to obey you I mean I
I know people who ride horses and horses
a big powerful animal too but we're
we're able as writers to tell the horses
and you know jockey issues their whips
to propel the horse and so forth you you
annoy a dragon he'll just turn his head
around and roast you or bite you in half
so it takes something more than physical
force it takes this kind of psychic bond
and the precise nature of that bond is
something that
I'm still exploring in a world of ice
and fire and and you know the the novels
yet to come and also the Targaryen
histories yes why
the Targaryen have this relationship
this connection with dragons well that's
that's something you have to keep
reading okay there'll be more of that in
both the novels to come and in and and
in fire and blood to come but you know
the Targaryen czar the last surviving
noble house of the freehold of malaria
which fell four hundred years before the
start of Game of Thrones in a cataclysm
that I mean it was dark in disguise
first was their fault
Valyrian yes they and they had a lot of
dragons and there were a lot of rival
Greg and writing families but only the
Targaryen sore the the doom of Valyria
coming and were able to get it get
themselves away long enough to spare
them and their beasts and it's
interesting because the connection
between the dragon and well let's say
the owner I don't know if the owner is
the correct words no I wouldn't say
owner writer writer okay it's
interesting because that connection can
be so strong that a dragon can kill
another dragon yes yes they're very
temperamental beasts they represent
power of course in in the books you know
I don't believe any more than Jay or
talking did in in fantasy novels as
allegory but there are certain things
you can you can look at the Dragons can
win wars for you yeah that's established
in the histories but they can't
necessarily produce peace or prosperity
or help you rule the nation you know
Daenerys Targaryen is finding it out in
Mereen when she you know she defeats the
cities of slavers Bay with her three
dragons but then in trying to rule as
Queen destroy marine anytime she wants
by just unleashing the dragons to kill a
lot of people
you know wipeout the most of the
population of the city reduced the
entire city to a fiery Inferno but that
doesn't help her come up with good laws
or to establish peace between the
original inhabitants and the freedmen
and people that she's brought in so
ruling is more than just the power to
destroy and that's a lesson that she's
definitely learning